cette époque époque chaotique malgré le
cessez-le-feu le fln répliquait aux
attentats de l'oas par des enlèvements
voici le témoignage d'un soldat français
qui en a été victime de ces enlèvements
il a été retenue dans un camp dans des
conditions très dures
ses compagnons de détention serait tous
morts document de christian hottin andré
aussignac est un rescapé en juillet 62
juste après l'indépendance de l'algérie
ce jeune appelé consignés dans sa
caserne à alger comme tous ses camarades
sort malgré tout pour acheter des
cigarettes
il tombe alors sur des policiers du fln
et là je me suis trouvé avec un barrage
avec l'impossibilité de me servir de mon
arme
peut-être heureusement et souliers de ma
montre les papiers et tous points aux
pieds toutes plus des bonu urgent une
bonne raclée en cet été 60 de la guerre
d'algérie est finie pourtant le fln
continuer à enlever des français par
dizaines andré aussignac est emprisonné
avec une soixantaine de civils européens
avant d'être transféré commence alors
une longue marche forcée il y avait déjà
un ticket n'est pas le coût qui tombait
et tout à l'heure où on pouvait les
cheveux lire c'est à dire leur mettre
des pierres dessus ce qui j'étais mots
ou alors on nous interdit d de les
secourir
donc j'ai vu des gens mourir comme ça où
cette marche oui oui oui oui et cette
marche a duré longtemps aussi oui c'est
à dire
suis-je pas poweo les survivants
finissent leur voyage dans une mine de
fer à une centaine de kilomètres d'alger
tortures humiliations aussignac et ses
codétenus deviennent des esclaves
on n'avait plus rien on était presque
nue n'y avait plus de nourriture ou de
la vue et se moulent de l'eau par qui
pratiquement pas c'est de là qu'on avait
coupé des lambeaux de tissu économique
et dans les failles de la mine pourquoi
elle se modifie et qu'ont reçue c'est ça
j'ai vu un punk ilham pouvait plus la
missa pioche thomson est ici j'étais le
chu il en est mort oui ce calvaire va
durer six mois après trois tentatives
d'évasion andré aussignac réussi à
gagner la france
grâce à des pieds noirs il ne pèse alors
plus que 40 kg mais il n'est pas au bout
de ses peines pour la france en paix
avec le nouvel état algérien aussignac
est un suspect je suspecte de tous de
désertion que je fasse une partie de
l'ol sous pour tout choix
hélas les autorités militaires des gens
vous font comprendre oui quels sont les
leviers je me taisais et ben moi et
pourquoi avez-vous tézier mais parce que
là bas il dit j'étais pas la guerre il
n'y a pas de prisonniers
quarante ans après andre aussignac veut
que la france reconnaisse le sort de ses
compagnons d'infortuné peu qui ne sont
jamais revenus